brewing giants like anheuser-busch and
Coors still dominate beer sales in this
country but independent Brewers have
been steadily gaining market share that
cosy craft brewery down the street is
part of an 80 billion dollar industry
and the bartender is one of 550,000
people working in craft brewing adding
an estimated 5 billion dollars to the
economy but now craft brewers fear their
profits could go flat if a provision in
the nation's tax law is allowed to
expire Barry Petersen has the story and
that was really a kind of a sugar yeah
it's a little fun fact from Denver craft
brewer
Judd bell stomp it's a got a molasses
character to it you got a little splash
on you there you go the more sugar you
add a higher the alcohol content in beer
and here's a not so fun fact a lot of
small craft brewers like they'll stock
our won tax break away from maybe going
out of business it ended up being about
a million dollars to to start the place
up and somebody says and by the way we
want you to pay more taxes what then
then I think there for me the only
option is to start raising prices well
it cuts sales oh absolutely the excise
tax was $7 a barrel it was cut in half
two years ago but that expires in
December Pennsylvania congressman Mike
Kelly is pushing to keep the cut for
small Brewers it's really critical that
if they can save cost anywhere they want
to do that because we'll take whatever
they save and put it back in equipment
or put it in hiring more people
recapitalizing their business
it makes me a jolly here's been part of
America before there was an America
arriving on the Mayflower
so does beer taxes and beer started the
first by American policy when George
Washington said he would only drink
american-made when Gold Rush prospectors
flooded the West beer came with them
Sam Bock is an historian at history
Colorado people were really happy to
have beer during the gold rush it was it
was a social lubricant it was a sign of
civilization it was like a lot of
history in this glass there's a ton of
history in this glass everything from
the style of the beer to the ingredients
we use to the processes to the laws that
govern its production and consumption
and today's craft breweries are still
making history this festival opened
crisis brewing company in Denver focused
on Hispanic beers one of the first in
the country and if it succeeds it will
double as an Hispanic community center
tamil' Maldonado is it co-owned micro
breweries and the craft beer industry
hasn't been a diversity fie and there
are reasons for that accessibility and
resources and financial reasons
so the taxation also helps or not helps
on that Judd bail stocks does lusus
beers actually a big step back into
history made from corn not hops using
three thousand-year-old recipes from
Peru in general the most popular is our
chicha ante our basic chicha and that is
that it's it's just easy drinking
medium-bodied
really nice solid beer it's got a little
bit of a kick and it's got a little bit
of a different taste to it and to
historian Bach there's one more reason
to help craft breweries each one of
those is
not just a place to get a beer it's a
community it's an entrepreneurs vision
and I think that those things are
critical to developing new vibrant
communities in cities around the country
for breweries whose profits are thin
keeping the cut could cut them the break
they need to make sure there's always a
beer on tank CBS this morning Saturday
Barry Petersen
I wonder regulators understand our
lawmakers what they're creating here
it's like the trickle-down effect it's
so difficult to launch a small brewery
like that and then stay in business so
we'll keep you posted